Human Services oversight committee and
welcome and would the clerk please call
representative Pearson here
representative McDonald not here
um representative Weber here
representative King here representative
Edwards here
representative Merchant here
representative Murphy here
representative or I'm sorry I am
extremely sorry Senator gray
Senator Rosenwald here
and Senator Senator eighthard minus
appendix is not here okay
um I believe we have a quorum thank you
very much let's take a look at the draft
minutes from March 24th we've some of us
have gone over this several times for
accuracy which is which is good enough
but would everybody take a look to see
Bluetooth
second
moved and seconded to approve any
further discussion
Senator Rosenwald since I was in here
I'll be abstaining you will abstain yes
thank you good thank you
anything else
hearing none all in favor of approving
the minutes say aye please
opposed
chair would like to call associate
commissioner Christine centeniello to
good morning commissioner Weaver was
unable to be here today so she actually
asked me to give two updates to the
committee if that's okay
all right perfect
um the first one and luckily we do have
Henry Littman here so um if we have
specific questions Henry can address
them
um when
um his time so first of all is Dental
um I think one of the critical pieces is
as you all know the dental benefit went
into effect April 1st this really has
filled an unmet need
um critical for many of our residents
there's many many stories I think one of
the most impactful is a person
um
who has never had dental treatment
before and when the benefit passed you
was actually able to see a dentist so
there's such a connection so that's
wonderful to date we have 112 unique
dental providers which is nearly
doubling the amount in a month
um there's 23 providers in 12 location
are in Border towns but services are
offered in 274 different locations Delta
yep I just want to be looking at what
you're looking at are you looking at at
this document where it says Network
recruitment dashboard yes
okay I just wasn't mapping the numbers
until has done
they have paid a provider sign-on bonus
um about a thousand dollars per office
and that'll go through the end of April
so that's been really helpful the mobile
van is returning to follow-up Karen
Colebrook on April 29th and May 12th and
13th in Concord
and was continuing to work on additional
come on up Henry there's going to be
questions
chair recognizes Senator Rosenwald with
a question yes thank you thank you for
this update do you have do we have any
sense of of the contracted providers
whether they're
taking them to the same extent
that they're accepting any other new
patients or are they saying yes I'll
sign the contract but then they take
a very limited number of Medicaid
patients do we know that
no but
I do think that um
has has come out in other discussions
about managing a practice that you know
a given practice that if they're an
independent practice has to manage their
their pair mix to a certain extent so
but we are trying to measure if you will
will be measuring that that the access
is comparable to what isn't in the
commercial Market that probably take a
little time to to evaluate thank you
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair
thank you for all the work that you're
putting in on us one of the things I'm
hoping to see at some point is a map of
New Hampshire that's got a heat map kind
of look to it to where places where we
don't have any uh any support would be
very Vis visually noticeable is that
coming next month you think or I believe
it is we did get a very extensive uh
sort of document on the different
mapping that Delta Dental is doing and
understanding that I think you might
have used the word utility that we want
something that you know it's not 84
pages in length but they're something
that we can sort of summarize that is
good from a policy maker standpoint
we'll work over the next month to get
that it would do me with just one page
basically it just had the picture of
where we're hot and we're cold and and
these statistics that you're running
here on contacts and everything this is
this is really good to have as well but
um and now am I asking you for something
that we don't have uh the right software
for to to
orders I don't want to accidentally be
asking you for this enormous
bureaucratic exercise to create a heat
map I'm assuming that there's a software
tool that could do this relatively
easily
so Delta Dental and their their partner
subcontractor that does administrative
Services is working with Delta Dental to
um to produce something along the lines
of what you have and what I'll try to do
is between now and next meeting give you
some updates on that um in terms of
getting to that heat map kind of concept
that we talked about it may take us a
couple tries but you know understand we
are trying to get to what you're trying
to get to
um and I would expect since their their
subcontract uh DentaQuest
um you know was the largest of all the
administrators in the in the Medicaid
space that they'll come to being able to
produce a product that will will meet
your needs in the committee's needs it's
just one small clarification I I hear
all that that's all great I I I just
don't want it to have to turn into some
big exercise to go buy some new software
somewhere and train people how to use it
and all that if I'm asking for something
that's not really practical just tell me
I think I would like to have what you're
talking about and I haven't reached a
point where I don't think that that's
possible without the state having to us
having to put more manpower or or uh
investment to get it if if we're running
into that I'll come back to you to let
you know and I'll try to let you know
early but we'll get you something thank
you representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair
and thank you again for the dashboard
it's very helpful
in regards to the 112 unique providers I
noticed that on the dashboard we have
both New Hampshire Vermont Maine and
mass is part of the catchment area
of the 112 unique providers how many of
those actually in New Hampshire versus
outside of New Hampshire
um off the top of my head it's 23 that
are our border so the balance to what's
that 90 uh close to 90 are in state
and the if I may follow up in regards to
the sign on bonus it sounds encouraging
to have that
what requirements involved for the sign
on bonus scope following up on Senator
rosenwald's question is there any
requirement for them to take a certain
number of patients in order to qualify
for the 1 000 bonus
um the the contract between the provider
um and Delta is not something that we're
um you know directly involved in
negotiating but you know the presumption
is that they're going to have a
reasonable
um level of access being provided some
of the
um the the Border uh might be a practice
like some of the uh like oral surgery
practices are you have a network that's
you know it's in more than one state so
that's some of that again I think the
ultimately in in healthcare practices
whether it be a a doctor's office or a
dentist or a hospital or nursing home
that you have to have some reasonable
pair mix that allows you to you know to
to keep the lights on and pay your staff
and that's I think you know the The
Challenge and and then the workforce
shortage too but you know I think the
things that we added to make sure that
people
um can get to their appointment but be a
transportation and that there's Care
Management to also make sure that they
get to the right place those are all
things that I think
um
and that the claims pay timely which I
think that's Delta's very good at doing
in the in the state that that as we you
know show that that's the way they're
going to experience it will do better
than if if that goes the other way
um so would it be possible for you to
get that language from Delta and bring
it to us next month uh because I
certainly would not wish that a given
dentist would take the thousand dollars
and see but one patient so I'd like to
see what the expectations even if
they're a bit General sure thank you
uh Senator gray not so much a question
but a comment
um you're talking about the dental
benefit I was at the Stratford County uh
public health network uh breakfast this
morning uh and you would think they were
talking about two different programs
okay
um you concentrated on what we've got
these improvements they're concentrating
on I still don't have dentists that will
take anybody because this dentist has
said I'm only going to take X this
dentist is agreed you know that was
those positions or those those patient
spots have already been so again not so
much question just a comment that you
know we've got a difference between what
what the state you know is saying what
the public health networks are saying
and we're not there yet and money is
probably you know the root of all that
and we've got budget with a 17 increase
right now and I keep telling the people
who do I take it from to give it to you
okay so I've made my statement now thank
you much
uh could you speak to that in terms of
how a better recruitment is ongoing and
be
um whatever else I just forgot so I
think one of the the points that we'd
like to convey is that you know that the
first day of service that we had uh uh
on April 1st uh Delta Dental to help
supplement the concern that you're
raising they they brought in a dental
mobile provider
and they saw 48 patients on the first
day through those two sites one in
Colebrook and one in Concord they're
coming back to do their follow-up visits
um I think one's coming today
um and um the first week in May then
they were working with Delta to try to
expand that capability to help fill in
some of the the issue that was raised
there in terms of as things stand up I
know if most of us if we called a
dentist no matter what the benefit we
would have today if you're going for
sort of a routine
um type of thing it's it can take months
to get an appointment but what we do
have is we have a you know Dr Finney and
the medical director at Delta Dental
that if you know there's a systemic
infection type issue that we're
concerned about they'll find a way to
get them seen and so we're not we're not
where we need to be but we're we're a
lot better than where we were and we're
going to get better as time goes on
is it on the is it planned for
representatives to go to the various New
Hampshire County Republican monthly
meetings and Democrat monthly meetings
we hadn't planned that but you had until
now what we had not planned that until
now until now that's that's what I
wanted thank you
representative Weber thank you
uh
not to belabor the point but
um with respect to the mapping uh what
would be very helpful if maps are
difficult in terms of software is to
know the exact town or municipality
because as I look at the county
breakdown if you map at a county level
it isn't going to tell me anything more
than this it if you look at the county
breakdown
the issues are as usual kawas only has
two and Grafton which is a huge County
only has three and I noticed that
Windsor Vermont which is convenient to
some but not much of Grafton County does
give us five more so that helps with the
river towns it just doesn't help with
anything in the warm mountainous part of
Grafton County so knowing exactly where
and it shouldn't be difficult in terms
of software just to provide a list of
towns and the number of providers per
down I today I have an Excel spreadsheet
that I could provide to give you the
exact address of everyone that's in the
network the the other thing that they're
doing
um in their Deltas doing they're
measuring what is the time and distance
standard to each of the practices so
they're they're really doing uh those
would be very helpful
in terms of trying to evaluate things
and and uh
I'm very pleased with the how they're
collaborating with us and trying to
representative Merchant but thank you Mr
chair one of the I served on a qualified
Healthcare board for several years and
one of the challenges we had was what
are called no shows and given the fact
that with Medicaid reimbursing being as
low as it is and to your point about the
provider having a good pair mix
do you know when the contract within
Delta Dental is the state willing to pay
for the no-show or at least to help
cover the provider because once the time
is evaporated that opportunity is lost
it's so the empty chair issue is one of
the key factors when we were talking
about the benefit with providers who are
involved in it and so our approach to
that is to provide a transportation
benefit so if transportation is a factor
and also care coordinators to to work
with people who may have
different issues that that make it
difficult for them to access the system
I think that we have to to test that
experience a little bit to to see
whether that's going to work or not but
I think you know that's a fundamental
issue if there's a lot of empty chair
time that's we're going to have to take
other actions to to close that because
that fundamentally is uh you know if
you're going to be altruistic
you you know to take your share if you
will then you know you don't want to be
penalized by both having to get nothing
and and pay for the staff and supplies
Etc are planned follow up and thank you
Mr and so going forward will there be
any tracking of that data to help us
understand this program because if we're
seeing a lot of empty chairs no shows
I'm concerned about the overall impact
we'll have with providers and they're
willingness to take on the program if
we're not finding a way to keep them
whole financially
I I don't have a specific answer today
seeing no further questions please
continue thank you so the next um topic
area is we just wanted to give an update
on the Medicaid unwind
um
that okay I'm just waving oh okay all
right
um so I think
um New Hampshire was one of the first
States
um to return to normal operations and
this was actually done with CMS approval
and primarily this is because New
Hampshire we had systems in place and
operations and we've been working on
this honestly since July of 2020. excuse
me associate commissioner um do we have
a handout on this and what does it look
like
if we do
oh it's hiding okay thank you sorry for
the interruption that's okay
um and so I think what's really
important
um we've heard heard a lot of
um
talk about the end of the continuous
coverage that we have saying people are
being terminated or kicked off of
Medicaid and I think we really want
we're trying to reframe that to be
people are in transition because some
people remain eligible
um because they still meet the
requirements others complete the
redetermination
um and yet also we're not able to retain
certain and eligible people so we're
working really hard
um with providing information about
other insurance sources we work closely
with the Department of Insurance The
Navigators and so we're really making
sure that if people aren't eligible
um we work through their case with them
and then also we refer them the right
way
we are taking a risk-based approach for
our procedures so we prioritized those
who
um we focused on the first month the
first couple of months are those who are
likely to be ineligible for Medicaid
based on income information they gave us
we also tracked it with people who
weren't using we took that group and
then looked at their claims over the
last few months so really to ensure that
those
um who are least vulnerable would be
worked on first and then we delayed
those who are more vulnerable towards
the end so we can continue to try to
keep people on so
um we believe that because of how we
approach this the number of individuals
who became eligible ineligible and
um March is probably our highest point
and then it'll continue to lessen over
thank you Mr could you help me
understand on the graph first of all
thank you for providing it's helpful
what the timeline is I'm assuming the
first number is like if you look at the
first one 51 366 is that back in March
of 2020 in the last data point is on
March 27th or April 24th
so thank you for the the questions so
what we've always been looking at is
from the time that sort of the
continuous enrollment
um kicked in so March 16th is roughly
that date March 16th of 2020. so we
we've been benchmarking against that
time the whole time through and so if
you look at the the top line of the
graph that
um the theoretical High Point was just
just before the end of March where we
had 96 515 people in granted Advantage
154 842 in standard for a total of 251
357.
um the next line down of numbers going
across the 81 773 is now what is in
granted Advantage as of Monday
um the standard program has gone to 143
793 so as of April um 24th the the
enrollment stood at 225 000 566. if you
drop down below that we've sort of
developed the the blue the blue column
if you will
um is measuring um against
um you know what that the maximum
enrollment was in and what the change in
enrollment has been since 328 of of
23. so what we're what we're seeing is
that
um you know the risk-based strategy that
Chris described is that uh
um in the first
um number of months here we're seeing
um a hot very high percentage of people
who are Income ineligible so those are
are individuals that were automatically
transferring to the uh to The Exchange
and what we understand
um is that the you know The Navigators
will be getting lists from The Exchange
to be able to make additional Outreach
first in the form of letter and then in
the form of follow-up calls so that
individuals who can't be eligible for
Medicaid
um you know that that's that's the the
biggest group right now we also have a
group of people that have
um aged out you know both in the terms
of uh individuals who are on granted
Advantage as an example who are now
Medicare eligible and we also had a
group of children that are no longer
children since this has gone on for
three years and then
um you know there are other people that
may have been categorically eligible and
aren't eligible anymore we're working on
refining our analysis of that
information every every week we meet
just every Friday to review sort of
metrics and
um we'll be able to I think as we get a
little bit more refinement here giving a
picture of what happens but
um
you know our Outreach efforts I think
are probably Second To None I think in
in the country in terms of what's been
done to try to give people a heads up
and and to have an opportunity and you
know we're also seeing that people will
close
um that you know we're looking at a sort
of a Lifeboat concept just because you
close doesn't mean that you can't reopen
and we've the numbers on this page
reflect the net effect of those two
things in about seven and a half percent
of the closures end up reopening because
they may not have provided information
but once they get the closure notice and
they actually close they come back and
we try to help them and there's also you
know special additional Outreach that's
going on on vulnerable populations so
someone may have aged out of Medicaid
um and on Medicare but still hasn't done
anything to sort of get coverage we're
we're making additional phone calls on
what we call high-touch individuals the
highly vulnerable and you know it's not
perfect because we we're working with
claims information to identify this type
of information but we certainly are
making I think a tremendous effort to to
reconnect people and and transitions are
people on Medicaid who lose coverage
have until July of of 24 to exercise a
special enrollment period and Medicare
individuals have six months from the
time
just one other piece I think we've done
a lot of work with providers knowing who
they're serving who needs a
redetermination and really connecting
with them as they see the people when
they come in their office when they do a
home visit yeah I think that that's been
a big part of our strategy is giving
them lists of their patients and what
their missing items are and so that they
can do Advanced Outreach the mental
health centers have been very good using
that information that's can be a tough
population to to um to get to complete
things and there's been some really good
work done by the providers as well as
our mcos thank you for being proactive
representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question uh I think Mr Lipman
may have actually answered it but I want
to be sure
um
when the commissioner was testifying it
was
um the phrase was used not able to
retain certain eligible people and am I
correct in assuming that those are the
people who remained eligible but did not
return their paperwork so those are the
people you were talking about about
getting picked up again once they
suddenly realized they didn't have the
coverage anymore now they're getting
paperwork in
it's actually two groups that were okay
103 000 individuals
as of Mark the end of March that were
what we call protected meaning that the
continuous coverage requirements that
that group we had originally forecasted
that about 87 of those people would
close in the first month in fact 71
percent did but the reason our closure
was approximately what we wanted to do
is those people who are just coming up
to their first time eligibility which we
didn't have information on there was a
certain closure rate that occurred there
so we're doing better on the on the on
the um the people who are in the
protected group and we need to do more I
think to to strengthen our Outreach
effort to people who've never had to
redetermine but haven't been protected
um by the law
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman I'm just trying to
understand the chart the top seven
categories all tend to go up over time
and then they decliff and go down the
last one the children with disabilities
continually goes down right from the
get-go is that because they time out
because of age or is a alternative
coverage or do they go into the adult
with disabilities category how why did
that number go down so steadily so we've
we've when we shared this information
before we've had governor and Council
we've got that that question it's a
great question what we've been looking
at it it's basically aging into a
different category aging so it's not an
alternative coverage of any sort
generally not okay thank you
meaning
more people age out than are being born
and coming in
know that someone who is say 16 at the
time of this and they're they're they
move and they're now 19 they may be in
the adult group as opposed to the the
Children's Group my question is why have
they not been replaced by newly born
people
um
so I in terms of of that I think that
that uh
generally we haven't seen the
applications because we've been
processing applications all the way
through when Chris talked about it and I
also think sometimes children may start
in under their family coverage
um potentially and then move into a
specific child with disabilities
sometimes that does happen so
representative Weber and isn't it
important for us to remember that
although all the other lines are in the
multiples of thousands here we're only
talking a change of uh just about 150
kids and and our birth rates are
declining is that what you were
referring to yeah
some on other things among other things
yes Senator Rosenwald thank you
um
so
I know that but you know but March of
2020 we had about 125
000 people on traditional Medicaid and
000 about on expansion are you expecting
by the end of this calendar year
we're going to get back to those numbers
or do you think we're still going to be
at a higher case load for one reason
for another
I think that
um you know again we've got like six
weeks of experience here we're moving
into the more challenging cases as we
progress in but I think we're going to
be approaching within a years of time of
March I think too where we were
um you know given the same economic
conditions today as you know the
employment and other things are at a
very low level that the economy has goes
into a recession that could affect the
the the the numbers but I think you'll
kind of on a steady state basis of where
we are now I think we are going to be
reapproaching that and it also as you
know that in the grand Advantage piece
that people cycle in off on that and so
you know depending on layoffs and other
things that go on in the world you know
I think New Hampshire's very pretty well
but other parts of the country depending
on the the concentration of their
industry you know there's a lot of I.T
layoffs going on now I can say a state
like California with the big uh vendors
there but this really granted Advantage
was driven by unemployment temporary
losses of coverage
Senator Rosenwald thank you
of the people who have been disenrolled
because you've determined they are no
longer eligible do you have a any
information for us on the
percentages of reasons is it because
their income is too high or they have
other insurance options or they've moved
or is there information you can provide
us yes it's not today some other time
yes I think that um to give you some
sense again with six weeks of
information about half the individuals
are related to income eligibility then
there is probably the next largest group
of people who despite all the efforts
didn't complete their their paperwork
but we're tracking that and we'll be
able to report on that uh but you know
the information is still kind of green
in terms of you know
relying on it completely but we we are I
think we've referred over close to 19
000 people so far to The Exchange
oh thank you representative Edwards
thank you Mr chair I first I I've been
hearing about the Medicaid unwind for
about a year in various venues and I
just really appreciate the assertiveness
with which the department has been
dealing with this this is you're going
to set us up for as much success as we
can get from a program like this so I
appreciate that
um I'm I'm curious
um I'm assuming that these numbers are
all
um uh embedded in our three mcos
business operations and so as I look at
it longer and longer I start to wonder
if all three of our mcos are going to
end up in
a relatively the same places where they
got started do we have any issues where
we need to worry that
by pulling some of the population out of
the business that we're going to
disproportionately harm one MCO over
another or are they all pretty much in
the same boat that's a very good
question uh so when we did the original
procurement and that went to effect in
September of 19 that generally what we
understood from The mcos Who bid at that
time that they needed at least 50 000
population to be able to um you know get
to a a viable
um if you will level to to make the
Investments
um you know one MCO is based on this
enrollment is just dropped below that
but when we started the program we had
reserve the right to be able to for
people who did not make a choice of
which plan that they wanted that we did
an algorithm to to try to get that that
one plan up to sort of the viability
level I think depending on on how that
goes we may have to use that tool again
because we benefit by having choice for
the beneficiaries and and and it helps
us in terms of controlling the cost and
the plan
um I do think that you know as a plan
matures they also have some
responsibility to do good marketing and
provide good services to get more people
to choose their plan so well I think we
can try to help we can't guarantee and
that's why I think if we were able to do
the next procurement that that you know
that will be a factor as to whether
someone wants to stay in the market and
some new someone new might come in
um
follow up
okay so this is this is what I'm storing
from what you just said that that it is
in fact uh an important state objective
for us to have at least three MCO so
that we can have a competitive situation
and that is it stands now there's some
indication that uh uh we may have some
challenges in that area but that you're
working through them as best you can but
ultimately at the end of the day this is
a competitive market and they have to
just perform
yes and I think that's you know the
plans that are been here will have been
in the the market for almost five years
and you know through this service and
their extra benefits that they might
offer is part of the way that they have
great that's all I have for the
Commissioners update today thank you Mr
lippman if we ever get a national
single-payer health program would you
you're up next all right so I guess the
the next topic you were looking computer
um
the next topic I think you wanted us to
address was Senate Bill uh 263 which I
know chairman McDonald uh is probably
better even better able to update than
than I can but uh as I think everybody
knows that came over from the the Senate
uh on the unanimous vote uh
HHS and DNA committee
um have their first discussions of that
at executive level
um there seems to be a number of uh of
issues that uh that members of the
committee wish to talk about and I don't
know whether it might be better to have
uh chairman McDonald to address that but
uh I can kick in here or however you'd
like me to
well let me ask chairman McDonald's to
hold forth and you folks can go you two
can go back and forth if you wish
without being recognized as nod thank
you
thank you Mr chairman
um Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs uh as since a number of the
committee members are present this
morning had an extensive discussion
about SB 63 263 this past Wednesday
we did not make any decisions it is
clear that there are numerous amendments
forthcoming on the bill that will be
discussed that our next executive
session is coming Wednesday but there
was extensive discussion on both sides
um pro and con as far as
as far as the sunset how long a sunset
should there be a sunset that was
obviously a main topic but um no votes
were taken no amendments were formally
considered a couple were distributed and
there are again numerous others
numerous numerous others apparently that
will be a forthcoming and we anticipate
we'll be discussing on the at this
upcoming executive session
um that's that's unfortunately that's
there's not a lot else I can I can share
but I certainly invite any other members
by May Mr chairman representative Weber
I may want to speak to this also
representative Weber thank you Mr
chairman and Mr chairman
um I I think it's important to recognize
that most of the discussion that
happened this past week was a far and
free-ranging discussion of the entire
state of the health care delivery system
in New Hampshire
uh the state of economics and social
opportunity in the entire world and uh
concerns about the Medicaid Program in
general and not a lot of specifics about
House Bill 263 so we're just going to
have to as far as I'm concerned we're
just going to have to wait and see how
that unfolds because a lot of what's
coming either hasn't been formulated yet
or hasn't been shared because there
might be more
formulation coming we have we have a
couple of specifics that have been
shared but I think that
those are fairly narrow and clear it's
the broader stuff that's going to be an
issue
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman uh yes it was as you know far
reaching and um uh discussion on
Wednesday
um but I think one of the
um more poignant you know uh concerns
that I heard
among others was the permanency issue
and I guess I would just like to hear
your thoughts about the pros and cons of
a two-year permanency five-year
permanency versus indefinite permanency
meaning that at some point if Medicaid
goes away as a federal program along
with the state I'm assuming that would
end our program here as well so I I
guess I would like your general thoughts
about the sequencing of two five and
then indefinite permanency
so on the the two-year standpoint I
think the advantage of that
time frame is that there's a formal Hab
as I think came out in committee
discussion there's you have to actually
reconsider it the the downside of it
from administering the program and
looking at you know what what is
probably larger than a six billion
dollar contract is that it puts us at a
disadvantage in terms of the competition
that we have in terms of trying to put
and maintain a contract in place
um
the The Five-Year
um you know I think generally what we
understood from the past procurement is
that
um there's a to be a new entrant as a
significant investment in terms of time
and effort to build out a network and
set up systems and what have you that
you know coming into the market not
knowing whether the Market's going to be
large enough to support a new entrant um
because if we lose the granted Advantage
Program it wouldn't be viable for for
three plans likely
um and so that that I think is a
disadvantage you know from an
Administration standpoint that that we
see
the way that the not have to I made a
note card on this to carry around with
me but the way the
um you can actually put all of this on a
notepad
the reauthorization
um you know if it was was done
um
see if I can read my notes
um you know I think that the the
misalignment of five years is that we
would we'd have like about
um nine months or eight months that
would be
um they'd be so uncertainty as to
whether it be renewed versus uh 34
months if it's a two-year
reauthorization which I think that's
that's my concern in terms of getting
the state the best deal and our
our beneficiaries the best benefit plan
that we can put in place if there's not
competition for
um that I think five years is a little
bit of uncertainty I think the market
can can can tolerate something like that
six years would be ideal because it
would cover the length of the the
reprocurement and we've been doing it in
five-year increments since the since
managed care even before we had rented
Advantage as a program I think uh
um you know the the other part of the
conversation that came up is every
whatever is passed is really good for
two years in the sense of that you know
the next legislature can come through
and do that but I think you know that
the practice has been to honor what's
been been passed um let me ask a
question let me ask a question about
this as a person who tries to be
compassionate and Frugal at the same
time sometimes pulling it off
um
would the cost of the two years
in a two-year plan be greater than the
first two years of A Five-Year Plan
given how bidding goes
I think the cost would be higher if
there's a two only a two-year and
effectively it's 16 months because the
the the current reauthorization runs
through December
um and so it would only be a 16-month
contract which is even worse than two
years for um someone who'll be
considering coming into the market as a
competitor could you has a
estimation as to the difference of two
years in a two-year plan versus the two
years of A Five-Year Plan with the two
years and a two-year plan be a ten
percent higher bid a 20 percent higher
bid what I guess even if it's a very low
percentage even if it was five percent
five percent on a six billion dollar
contracts real money
um and so I guess you know a range I
would put would be probably in the five
to to ten percent as being you know a
reasonable planning uh number
um because you know underlying
um you know any contract is ultimately
the the medical costs that that have to
be incurred
um irrespective
representative Weber
sorry I jumped in thank you and just so
we're clear
um if if we're setting aside the
two-year plan
um and going with something that meshes
with a five-year procurement
interval isn't it true that we really
need to talk about a six-year and you
said this already but I just want to be
sure we're all clear about it because we
keep throwing out the five-year
extension and isn't it true that if
we're going to cover the full
period of another five-year contract we
need to have that six-year extension
that you referred to so we should all be
in our brains adjusting to a six-year
extension if we want if what we want to
do is cover the next contract cycle that
is correct okay I just I just want to be
really clear on that because for those
of us who do not sit on finance and
can't remember which
July then the next fiscal year starts at
um
I know but but I can never remember
whether it's the date that's ahead or
it's the year right
um anyway those of us who have trouble
calculating that if we could just all
remember that uh to cover a full
contract renewal we need to do a
six-year extension if that is our intent
yes I think that when I talk five years
I think what to me again this is my my
view of it and that there could be
alternative viewers I think it shows
that the state has at least the
commitment equal to what it entered into
this contract because we've got a
five-year reauthorization I think that
sends a different signal to the
marketplace
um six years I think is guarantees us
that they understand we're there um five
years could work as well but you know it
does have it could have some impact that
I can't quantify for you exactly but I
do think sending a signal that we're
less committed to the program uh like
with a two-year reauthorization does
affect I think you know what the
administrative side of this looks like
Murphy
thank Mr chairman uh just a follow-up
and I think it was just a dress but I
just want to be clear and in the spirit
of compromise and as we will be
addressing this obviously next Wednesday
once again and also coming from somebody
who will obviously be running the
national Healthcare program as
representative Edwards suggested my I'm
taking the blame for that
my question is I just want to be clear
you know as opposed to permanency into
the future indefinitely Or a two-year
plan in the ideal World running this
administratively as a six-year
extension of the program give you
comfort in running the program for the
benefit of efficiency and for the
uh I've heard Mr lutman also that in
terms of debating the five versus six
versus two uh it's my understanding
anything less than five it's very hard
to get people to bid is that correct
also yes because of the if you're
looking to be having new entrants as a
possibility encourages everybody to
sharpen their pencil and what they're
going to offer and how they're going to
work with us
um so I think you know when you can't
recover your investment there's a lot of
time that a new entrant has to spend in
terms of developing you know a contract
with you know thousands of providers and
you know setting up the systems and
hiring people that if you're you know if
you don't have some reasonable a period
of time and there was always a risk
wreck because of the legislature could
come in and do something different but I
think reasonably you know the the
legislative intent that uh is passed I
think generally would be I think a
strong enough signal to to get people to
be interested in it and I you know have
had
um other than those that are in the
entrance that are in the market today
who have expressed interest at least
exploring what the opportunity might be
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman
oh one of the things we I heard anyways
during the
Committee hearing on Wednesday
and it goes back to the two year five
year six years and so forth and I
totally understand where you're coming
from because
you'd be looking for a new entrance into
the marketplace to put pressure on the
ones that are existing is it's a way to
do it is how the free market works
however there's a concern also that if
we go for five years that we don't have
a legislative review or
until five or six years after it's
passed is there any way to build into
the commission that was being created
through SB 263
benchmarks that if they don't hit
certain benchmarks it would require a
legislative review at that point in time
so it's sort of a compromise saying it's
not going to be stripping six years
before the legislative body reviews it
again but there's some Assurance within
the process that there is the ability to
put metrics in place to ensure we're
hitting some sort of metrics either
Financial patient satisfaction whatever
it may be
I do think that in terms of the the
commission structure that was another
thing that I think when Senator Bradley
testified originally to the committee on
when he introduced the bill to to your
community uh chairman McDonald he there
was a question about would there be some
tweaks to the I don't remember
specifically what they were to the the
commission
um I think that's a place where you know
you want a higher level of scrutiny as
it's going along I think one of the
arguments that I heard was that you know
if you do
the permanency then people just don't
pay attention to it and if you do five
years that's five years when they'll pay
attention to it or six years it'll be
six years when they pay attention to it
I think if if the commission is staffed
or appointed with the right people that
that's I think probably the best thing
as opposed to you know
um other things in terms of making sure
that it's the program's working you know
balancing the the benefits that people
are receiving and the health outcomes
and and how the rest of the insurance
Market's working because today I think
you know I've tried to in various venues
is that you know New Hampshire's got the
number one highest employer sponsored
insurance which is you know a function I
think of two things one that the the
marketplace is available to help people
who aren't necessarily you know they're
small pool so that a difficult risk to
underwrite and in that market with the
1332 waiver we've got the lowest
Benchmark premium in the country on the
Medicaid side we've got a pool of
individuals that have tend to have more
complex needs and by having three
structured pools you know that's
probably an oversimplification you know
our markets in terms of you want
employers to offer Insurance you want
the marketplace to be you know
reasonable and I put reasonable in the
air quotes because Health Care is not
reasonable no matter what you price it
up and then you know you've got the
Medicaid Program which you know I think
we're running at a at a pretty efficient
rate overall in terms of our cost per
person
you do realize when you go Federal we
will still be your oversight committee
enjoy that thank you so much thank you
thank you so much see you next month
the chair recognizes Melissa Hardy and
Sandy pharaohs from the Bureau of
Developmental Services
regarding redesign implementation status
good morning I'm Melissa Hardy I am the
division director for long-term supports
and services
hi good morning I'm Sandy Pharos I'm the
bureau chief at the Bureau of
I just wanted to provide a quick
um update from our last or site meeting
last month on the retained House Bill
608 as far as the developmental Services
redesign implementation project
what I handed out is just an update from
last month to current as to kind of what
our
involvement has been with stakeholders
with families with some advocacy groups
as far as talking about the redesign
process
um
House Bill 608 particularly talked about
piloting some of the services which
we're still planning to do however we
have not started that process as we're
still working towards compliance for our
corrective action plan on seven one of
this year so
um I'd be happy to take any questions or
feedback if you would like different or
more information about 608 and this well
first of all the chair would like to
thank you because we've had some
conversations about how I gave myself a
good talk that I haven't talked with
either my Downstream staff or the people
who come to us for care and in doing
that I shared that with you and I want
to thank you for what I've been hearing
and with my ear to the ground and spot
checking we're getting there we're going
to do more I know that and thank you for
the progress thank you
representative Edwards uh yes sir I I
have several questions just about
reporting methodology and and formats
and some of them are kind of in the
weeds I I can either take them offline
or ask about four or five questions in
public which whatever you prefer I would
prefer to let people with the single
question and one follow-up go first and
then um all right we'll go back to you
Senator Rosenwald thank you very much
um I missed the last couple meetings so
I've missed the updates but I do know
that there are some significant level of
concern among families in the
developmental Services communities they
don't feel that they're necessarily
being listened to by the department so I
just want to lay that out there again
because there there is a concern and I
guess my specific
question on this is
I still don't understand how
the department can save money
and deliver the same level and quality
of services
in these programs particularly As We
Know
costs are going up wages are increasing
so so I'm still
confused myself sure thank you thank you
for that comment I I don't think the
department takes the stance that this is
a cost savings for the this program
um what we have had is you know
um no historical methodology and
developing rates for services that kept
up with inflation that kept up with the
costs of doing service so part of the
whole redesign is to look at the costs
and what are we reimbursing as far as
thank you so unless this is a different
proposal but it was the marsal
report I'm referring to Alvarez and
Marcel there was projected to be a
cost-saving of something like 40 million
dollars so has the department walked
away from the notion that there will be
cost savings I I would have to look back
at what the what the a m report had said
about cost savings I'm not sure it was
I see Chris coming up here as far as the
sorry about that Chris Antonello
associate commissioner the Alvarez and
Marcels report came in two phases the
first phase looked at that 40 million
dollar savings and that was really
related to wait list
last year the other
savings
that's where the savings were then the
Alvarez Alvarez and Marcel a m report
looked at better ways to utilize funding
and matching service needs with rates
with budgets and that's some of the work
we're doing in the next year around the
thank you and so I recall that report
though phase two had three two or three
different tiers of service people were
going to be put into one tier or another
and I think there were cost savings
projections
there as well and that's the part that
was concerning to the totally
understands and so that piece
potentially and we actually put the
tiered waiver work on hold because of
all the concerns we heard from families
and so what this department will be
doing
in the fall winter is look at okay what
services and they're started some of
that work do we need to have where do we
need to have it um is it in the DD
waiver is it in a different waiver so
that was put on hold
on yeah
Senator Rosenwald and I both raised the
question of stakeholders being listened
to more we raised it in different ways
but it was the same point could you take
a minute or two and and just give a
little oversight about what you've got
planned in the next few months with both
the area agency leaders and with
individual stakeholders sure so one of
the upcoming series that we're doing is
just a brief snippet online for families
using our communication committee and
then we will be going back kind of on
our road show again for individuals and
families to have some face-to-face
meetings with them to talk about their
concerns and you know really wanting to
hear from them directly as individuals
and families utilizing Services what
their concerns are so we also as I think
as you know representative Pearson we
have a newsletter that should be going
out I believe
within the next couple of days that
we've been doing quarterly yeah and
you're you're all I think you're on the
list right
um to receive it so with area agencies
we've been meeting uh weekly with csni
which is their Trade Organization myself
and Associate commissioner Chris
Antonello have been meeting with them
weekly and really trying to collaborate
on on a plan and where some of our pinch
points may be so we have been doing that
just just a thought in that I bring
my work as chairman of the New Hampshire
commission for the deaf and hard of
hearing we've got three different groups
out there that are advocacy groups for
the same population
like you do
and I find it's very very helpful
sometimes
to work with and through those groups
and sometimes not
and that way should there be the
hypothetical of any particular advocacy
group wanting too much to guard the door
I have a way to speak to
deaf and hard of hearing individuals and
their caregivers and loved ones that
both take into account the strengths of
the advocacy groups and also the
weaknesses and it's just free advice
um
yeah I think we welcome any invitation
from any of the advocacy groups we've
met with a couple this past month as far
as we were welcomed into their meetings
to kind of do a q a and have that
one-on-one time with the department so
we met with the able Group which is an
advocacy group we also met with New
Hampshire disability voice and choice
who has a different
um kind of take on the whole system's
work so we're we're open and willing to
talk to whoever you know wants to talk
to us and if we can reach out to anybody
that you know you're hearing from or
have concerns from where we're
absolutely willing to do that how are
you getting more names for your
newsletter mailing list more names of
individuals out there sure I think what
as we're doing more stakeholder
engagement and provider education I
would say we're pretty flooded with can
you add me to your mailing list
um which is good because we want to be
able to streamline our communication in
a quick way
um to everybody so we I think certainly
our efforts have been helping maintain
and build that list I found in the deaf
and hard of hearing community that some
of those names came forward from
advocacy groups
and then I started calling audiologists
individually and said I can't ask you to
do a HIPAA violation but I can ask you
to type this out and give it to every
one of your patients that if you want to
be on our mailing list you can be and so
you have to contact us so therefore no
HIPAA rule violation but it does reach
out into the community more fully great
you probably already know that but I
appreciate it I think I figured that out
a few years ago any other questions
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman I actually have
two questions one's a clarifying
a question the other one's an inquiry on
the
charts that we handed out there is the
pie charts and there's also bar charts
and I've noticed that on the bar chart
there's no delay the back clock if you
will however when I look on the pie
chart here's the orange and the blue and
the orange indicates that people that
don't have service that are waiting so
I'm trying to pull together why the pie
chart has the two orange and blue but on
the bar chart there's nothing showing a
delight sure and I think that's our our
next topic but
um
so for the bar chart that is the funding
waiting list so people who have
requested funding have received funding
and then the pie charts talk about the
service delivery
um that they're actually receiving so we
don't have a waitlist for funding people
for services but because of mostly
Workforce which you'll see on the pie
chart they're waiting to receive
services but not due to a funding issue
thank you for the verification the
inquiry yes the inquiry question is
along this journey we talked about some
sort of software implementation and
trying to make the changes along that
Journey can you provide an update of
where are we with that software update
as far as how are we in a process of
implementing it are we still exploring
it where are we in regards to that
software sure we're we are very excited
about the software I'm not a software
person but
um certainly it'll be an upgrade from
what we're doing now
um it is in a few phases so the first
phase uh will be turned on
um on seven one I believe
um as far as automating some of the
processes that our department and the
area agencies and providers do manually
whether it's via email via fax so we're
we're certainly excited about that and
then moving into the future getting
things like our prior authorizations
automated which again will get money out
thank you Mr chairman
um is the enthusiasm of the software
update shared with the stakeholders as
well
they haven't
I I I don't want to speak for them but
they haven't said uh that they're not
excited about it they're probably not as
excited as we are however
um you know I think anything that
automates a process and makes services
and and money flow out quicker I think
is a really beneficial for individuals
I issued a press release when the deaf
and hard of hearing committee through my
predecessor and my people on the
committee issued a handy motorists card
I got a press release out to everybody
and local police departments were so
inundated with requests can I have one
of those cards that we had to go to a
second printing privately funded and so
my suggestion is get everybody excited
write a wonderful press release coming
to a DD community near you is ta-da the
new software and here's why this is so
important and all newspapers please
print
you gotta you got to get out there thank
you yeah
of McDonald
my last name is not Edwards thank you
sir yeah no not not that I would mind if
it were
just to clarify on the pie charts uh the
in-home supports and the acquired brain
disorder talks about individuals
projected to start Services by March
31st I'm assuming that should be 2023
not 2022.
yes that's correct thank you just want
to make sure I wasn't a year behind or
and now
as promised
representative Edwards why don't you
take 10 minutes without asking me to let
you go another 30 seconds so you've got
it all right thank you I actually had
one item that I wanted to mention
um sort of before diving into this uh
and that is that I've had uh the the
pleasure of uh visiting uh uh Miss Santa
nella's office with Miss Hardy they were
very courteous they offered me lots of
chocolates so I I want to go back
sometime and visit some more uh they're
they're over in the the campus over
there
um so
um but but one of the takeaways and and
I had to flee the building for another
meeting so we didn't quite finish up and
um and so I've had some time to think
about it we the the one of the things
that uh I've observed is a very specific
uh client communication an issue that
the bds's experiencing and it's related
very to a very specific topic about
whether or not a a parent can take their
DD child into a recreational facility
and what and when they do what gets re
what's reimbursable and what's not and
uh and I I understand that the CMS
guidelines are pretty clear that the
price of admission is not covered but if
there's uh extra costs associated with
an escort of some kind that that sort of
supplemental cost to make the experience
possible is reimbursable so so having
been an old army comptroller uh I I
understood sort of the branch conditions
on this but but then when I continue to
hear from the individuals and I continue
to hear from
certain members of cisney not the whole
seasoning but aspects assisting and then
continue to hear from the Senator's
office it just seemed to me like this is
such a simple small thing that's
exploded into just a communication
tornado of some kind I don't I don't
understand I I I would like it I would
appreciate it if you could
provide me specifically in the CMS
guidelines you know page chapter line
item this yellow highlighted exactly
what the department is
um citing as the official Point of
Departure for your decision because the
community seems to think that you're
operating in an area of discretion and
and I picked up that you're operating
from an area of of direct guidance or
limitation and so the distinction
between doing what you're told in the
words of the CMS guidelines and whether
or not you have discretion is really
captured in the write-up from CMS so if
you could bring my attention to that
that would at least help me understand
not just the specific issue but the
bigger context which is why are we
having so so much trouble
communicating with the with the public
or the public hearing it and I I don't
mean to bash you because I I see I see
your document where you've got all the
meetings you're going to the dates that
you went to I have absolutely no doubt
that you guys are trying I'm just trying
to understand how it can maintain such a
huge disconnect with all of the efforts
the good efforts that you all are making
and and so if I could just take a look
at this one residential or excuse me
recreational issue that would help me
understand maybe you know what the
Genesis of these points of contention
are so
and so I I just as a follow-up we met
with some of these families that you're
mentioning actually this week about
their concerns with the recreational
coverage we also reached out to
um our our national organization that
liaises with CMS about additional
guidance so we can certainly provide
that to you
all right thanks and and sort of the
break point is
are you following a mandatory guideline
or are you following are you
interpreting it in a way in which you
have discretion and you're choosing to
go the other ways that we don't have to
answer that today but that's kind of
where I want to end up because one or a
zero at this point do area agencies have
discretion within themselves so one Area
Agency may do it one way and another a
different way
I I think that has been a historical
practice where they have had discretion
however when we have asked CMS directly
for that guidance
um and that's what we're following now
is their guidance that things such as a
recreational pass are not covered by the
waiver however things that like you said
representative Edwards if somebody needs
a direct support professional or
transportation to and from said activity
those those are the types of things that
are covered so because this has been
brought up we've directly gone to CMS
that have been following their
recommendations to us but we can provide
you with that detail I understand that
you have to give your area agencies uh
some flexibility yeah but when I get a
phone call from somebody saying this
wasn't covered but my cousin has a DD
person in a different part of the state
and it was I I don't have the answer and
if the answer is different area agencies
have different discretion at this time
before you make them do it all in a
uniform way that's a bit of information
that can be communicated as well because
I I had no answer to them sure I also
think that certain area agencies have
other types of dollars that they can use
to pay for some of these activities that
are not covered under the waiver so they
have family support Council dollars they
have fundraising dollars they have
Community Partnerships that they can
utilize too so I think that's where we
see some of the differences between the
area agencies again communication
foreign
so I don't want I don't want to leave
that topic making it sound or feel like
I'm I'm picking on you all or beating up
on you it's just an entire it's an
extremely complex area where you have
thousands of clients every one of your
clients is deeply emotionally engaged in
the problems that they're trying to
address and and you're sort of stuck in
the role in a way of having to be the
well-managed bureaucrats that are sort
of out of sync with the emotional aspect
of what they're what your clients are
dealing with so it's inherently tough so
I um
I I'd like to talk about the the format
of the reporting if I may now Mr chair
okay so we representative Merchant you
put your finger right on something big
that we've been talking about for
probably nine months or longer and that
is uh on the last document that shows
that there is no wait list this is
because this is what's been getting
reported to us is that we have fully
funded the wait list that's our legal
obligation and but that never got to the
questions that are answered by the pie
chart and so these pie charts these are
the first times I think we've seen these
pie charts right I think we've provided
them last last time but um yes we're
this is something we would like to do
ongoing if it's information you find
valuable oh okay so this is the
distinction between Our budgetary
obligation and what's really happening
out in the state of New Hampshire and
what we really care about I think is you
know that we we know what's really going
on and so you've got on the first chart
um you've got 677 individuals and and it
just makes me curious how many did we
fund for you don't have to answer that
right now I'm just I'm just going
through some of the questions that that
get triggered when I look at your your
data and so uh so obviously we funded
for all of them it's probably a number
that's different than 677 though so so
it would be interesting to know how much
we funded for how many are actually
coming to our doors to asking for help
and then how many of those are we're
just not able to help
and your top delay reasons you have
securing a vendor agency 28 of those in
that unserved category are having what
what does that mean they they there
there's not one of the 10 area agencies
that are working with them or why is
that yeah not
curing a vendor to provide the services
that are being requested
okay so so maybe I'm misinterpreting the
use of the word agency there that the
agency is having trouble finding a
provider correct is that a would be a
better way to say that bullet or am I
just misinterpreting it still
so this is a good distinction vendor
agency meaning the area agency cannot
find the vendor agency once they find an
agency if the agency says we're having
difficulty hiring staff that's the 47
number above the 28 so the majority of
people are not starting or have a delay
because there's inability to identify
staff right and there is a provider
agency selected right that agency is
having difficulty the 28 is there are no
agencies responding
okay all right so I guess I just need to
learn the bullet then because you just
told me the board agency is being used
in two different ways Area Agency and
the next level yeah and remember who
you're dealing with simple legislators
you know you gotta the kiss principle
right keep it simple for the stupid bit
um
all right continue and then
uh I think what this implies then is
this these are all snapshots at a given
time and that there's going to be Trend
data provided so that so that we can see
some of these things over time like uh
you know if we we we want to know if the
problem's getting better or worse and
and that's what the trend lines would be
but uh I when I first saw these last
night I I was very excited because I was
uh this is just something I think we've
always needed and I appreciate it uh how
how tough is it to get this data
is this is this a hard report to produce
once you get started is it easy to keep
up with the data or is this a pain in
the neck every single month well I think
going back to the the previous question
about the I.T system currently this is
all gathered
um by hand uh with our department
working with the area agencies to
collect that information with I.T system
as it comes online this should be more
of an automated process where we will
know and be able to pull reports from
New Heights to get this information but
as of right now it's a manual pull on
the BDS team but also on the area agency
team reporting that data out to us so
say again when you think you're going to
go live on your it system
um
up and running so while you're doing
this in the manual phase what's a
reasonable uh workload to put on you
once a month once every quarter what's
what's the right timeline given the
Manpower
I think we've I think what we've been
doing is a quarter we've been keeping up
with it quarterly and I think that's
pretty doable I think monthly would be a
burden for the not only for the
department but for the area agencies all
right that's it for me
thank you Mr chair
the representative yields back the rest
of his time Senator Rosenwald thank you
I just have
one question do you get claims data
on these Services through the mmis
system
we can we can capture claims data
through mmis one of the challenges is
when there's a prior authorization or
also known as a PA that may or may not
be billed out so it would be nice to
have a snapshot of what services have
been utilized
but without knowing what's been billed
out the claims data is just going to
tell us what's been built
so we have to know what's been allocated
and then what's been billed and then
that will tell us our utilization
thank you basically cash versus accrual
representative Merchant if I could
follow up thank you Mr chairman well in
the representative Edwards
I think I heard the fact that the pie
charts are something you're doing
periodically
and yes so we're doing it probably will
be on a quarterly basis yes is there a
way to take the pie charts like you did
with a bar chart and map it over a trend
line sure thank you we're not seeing the
needle move I mean the 30 to 20 number
of people not receiving Services seems
to be pretty consistent but we can
certainly show that Trend in our next
opportunity to present to the committee
thank you
I know in the Medical Counseling massage
organization of which I'm part-time CEO
we are now helping people with their
tuitions as they are in school in
exchange for working for us in order to
help the area agencies find more
providers of various types is this
something that is doable something
you're thinking true working with the
area agencies where are the people you
need that where are the gaps where are
the holes where are the schools where
are the people out there who aren't
applying to the school because they
don't have the money but if suddenly
they discovered an area agency might
prevent some money for them maybe not
having to be paid back maybe over a
period but you got to work first for so
many we just heard about that uh well
last time with dental students and maybe
this is something that might work for
you folks too
I was just going to say that the
corollary to that and I can't remember
whether I heard it here or somewhere
else
is that if you're doing one of these
programs where you get somebody uh you
help with tuition so that they can
come to work for you uh it's it's
actually one of the things that seems to
work really efficiently is they take out
the student loans and then each
period that the student loan comes do
you pay the student loan or whatever
percentage of it you've agreed to pay
and the reason is is that if you
structure it that way you have not paid
the tuition up front right uh and had
somebody go Waltzing off or or really be
willing to pay it back but then they
have a catastrophic illness or something
but you also have uh the incentive for
somebody to stay
and neither side is going to lose out
financially either because they didn't
complete the length of time or because
you said you were going to pay for them
and you didn't
um and and it just is is a nice seems to
me to be a sensible Arrangement so I put
it Forward whenever this question comes
up and I'm taking this to my board of
directors that's brilliant thank you so
much
thank you
and thank you
and representatives say hi to the
Richard now recognizes Michael Holt from
the prescription drug monitoring program
to present the annual report
you know the first requirement of
testifying here don't you
Miss myself that's the second one
smile you just did the first one
you turned on the mic and you smiled now
I got that I got that in from you
[Music]
you may go go ahead I'm just gonna thank
everybody my name is Michael Holt I'm
the section administrator for the
division of Public Health Services and I
oversee the prescription drug monitoring
program and the therapeutic cannabis
program okay that was my question
so it's the prescription drug and the
non-prescription drug
that's correct I apologize for that
um I'm here today to present the state
fiscal year 2022 annual report for the
pdmp uh it's a report required by
Statute required to be presented to this
uh this body uh and it contains data for
State fiscal year 2022 so that's means
July 2021 through June 2022 so the data
is a bit uh it's old on the on the older
side my presentation will present
information from this reporting period
and also updates from the uh the current
uh State fiscal year
um as you all know 2022 was a year of
transition for the pdmp it was
transferred via House Bill 2 from oplc
to DHHS uh PDP staff was transferred as
well
um at that time the other program
administrator position had been vacant
for almost a year from Spring 21 to
Spring 22. we filled the program
administrator position in April 22 Sean
Jackson is sitting behind us he'll
um he served a full year and has been
recently promoted and uh the position is
vacant once again we're trying to
recruit for that
um other than the agency transfer
um another the other significant change
in 2022 was the passage of Senate Bill
45 which allowed this was a long-term
goal of the pdmp and the bill permitted
the integration of pdmp data into New
Hampshire practitioners electronic
health record-keeping systems basically
integrating pdmp data into the clinical
workflow into the ehrs
um into
yes I'll tell you all about that right
now
um it's uh the value is that it becomes
part of the clinical workflow there's no
delay on practitioners don't need to go
outside into another web-based server uh
to access a separate web-based platform
to acquire the pdmp when they're seeing
patients
um
it makes access to PDP data more
efficient promotes compliance with state
state laws for mandatory use and
contributes to clinical outcomes
um
foreign
so another another Milestone
um in January 2022 we entered a new
state contract with uh bamboo Health the
software company that provides the pdmp
data system for New Hampshire
um the contract includes multiple
enhancements to the pdmp including
direct support for pdmp integration
um the integration product is called PMP
Gateway we launched it in March 2022 and
if you go to slide 12
shows that in the first three months of
implementation the number of pdmp
queries increased dramatically by 36
percent and uh and has continued to
increase so the goal of the goal of
increased utilization through EHR
integration of pdmp data uh is has been
has been borne out
um dramatically
um we are using Federal CDC funds to
fully fund
um the first two years of Gateway
integration through January 2024 for any
health care entity in the state that
wants to integrate
uh despite active marketing Outreach and
partnership with the New Hampshire
Hospital Association uptake of the
service has been surprisingly slower
than expected with only a 15 penetration
rate for prescribers in the state
um we continue to Market uh we continue
to do Outreach and we continue to
partner with the hospital Association
um some of the reasons may be the
technological you know work uh in
integration uh using
um the system uh the hospital Healthcare
entities existing EHR vendors others
might be simply
well once the funding runs out we're
going to have to pay for it ourselves so
best not to give or um our our
prescribers what they want for fear of
having to pay for it at the end of the
funding period so again this is ongoing
work for us
um and um to uh to increase uptake uh
Market the value of this and do Outreach
to Providers uh individually to to push
their uh their their health care
entities
um to adopt this uh this excellent
service
um another significant enhancement that
we launched in 2022
um as a software product called narx
care
um you can uh this enhancement is decide
on just described on slides eight
through ten
um narx care is a it provides enhanced
patient prescription history reporting
for prescribers including risk scores
proprietary risk scores that are
developed by our vendor interactive data
visualizations and a Communications
module where prescribers can communicate
with one another through the system
um and the feedback that we've gotten
from the new visualizations and tools
um the pdmp is still dealing with
another significant statutory change
resulting from House Bill 2
um we're on our way to fixing it
um but remember that uh House Bill 2
changed the confidentiality standard
um applicable to the release of pdmp
data the law sites what is known as the
HIPAA Safe Harbor standard and in part
this means that all location data
smaller than the entire State need to be
removed from any aggregate data released
including city and county the only
exception to this would be as an
allowance to use the first three digits
of a zip code this is called zip three
and so last year's annual report and
this year's annual report present all
location data in terms of um not County
data but in terms of zip 3 data let me
interrupt you to say that there are wide
swaths of the state and swaths of the
state that are not wide but still have a
lot of people in them but there's one
who's done bulk mails all his adult life
I know we have uh I'd probably say 033
and maybe 031 who are narrower and if
don't worry if I get the numbers wrong
but there are certain first three zip
codes that population wise are are quite
narrow do you think that is posing any
problem
uh well the zip 3 standard that were
that were on using the past two years is
problematic because it creates
inconsistencies for historical data
um you know I mean if you look at page
uh if you look at page four of the
report you can see the zip3 map overlaid
on counties and and they don't match up
so you know this is the same issue that
we ran into last year where we um we're
we're presenting locational data you
know that we presented for the past you
know five or six or eight years but it
it's not consistent with previous data
it also creates barriers for
um other uh entities and other partners
to use county level prescription data
from the pdmp so it's been about been a
couple years of not being able to
actively use our data in in the most
efficient way however the good news is
that
um to fix this unintended consequence we
have HHS requested legislation
um this session to allow the pdmp to
release data by County
um as an exception to the safe harbor
standard I want to thank Senator gray
for sponsoring that legislation
um it's Senate bills 34 it is past the
Senate
um and recently passed um got an OTP
recommendation from uh representative
McDonald's committee
um HHS and EA so if it all goes well uh
starting fiscal year 24 we'll be able to
release
county level data once again so we're
looking forward to that thank you
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair and uh it's good seeing you again
Mr hole I had wondered what happened to
you after you uh you moved off our
marijuana Plantation on the Cannabis
Medical Care you'll see me in a couple
weeks reporting some cannabis
information for you so
um I I this is a very thick thorough
report and it feels to me like it buries
the lead a little bit and I'll just tell
you how how I'm I'm looking at the
report and I'm wondering if the format
next year may want to be tweaked a
little bit there's a lot of great
supporting documentation but it seems
like page five at the bottom of page
five the prescription prescribing Trends
is is is maybe the headline and it and
it gets buried a little but you know
because what we're trying to figure out
is do we have a increasing or potential
problem in the future or are we getting
something mitigated we've worried a bit
about in the past so so this this
prescribing Trends which seems to want
to be a major element and then when you
look at the stimulates and it says it's
being increased you go flip to the
stimulants pages on pages like 32 and
Beyond and it it provides some data but
it doesn't offer any explanations of why
this trend may be occurring it's just
documenting the fact that the trend
exists and I wish Dr Murphy were still
here because he may have some clinical
Insight but in without having a
clinician available
um it just it begs the question in my
mind is why are we seeing an uptick in
stimulants and it's predominantly all
the young people and not us old people I
guess we can't be stimulated anymore but
uh but in any case I I I think it's a
really thorough report and it's mandated
by law but it it could be a little bit
more useful in terms of highlighting
what we really need to know about does
New Hampshire have a problem and and why
might we have a problem
uh thank you for the feedback I'm happy
to take that back and make some
improvements in terms of structure one
man's opinion
absolutely thank you
um I mean with that introduction I'm
happy to run through uh some of the uh
the report itself highlighting some of
the data
um as representative Edwards uh States
the the if you go to page five it
introduces some of the you know the high
level
um high-level Trends uh for Staples
skier 2022
um registering counts have increased by
8.4 percent
um our five-year look back has uh shows
an increase of uh a 58 registrant
accounts since 2018.
um 2022 we had patient queries performed
by practitioners uh increased by 14
um that a lot of that is attributable to
um to the Gateway integration that was
successfully implemented uh the spring
of last year
um and um yeah if you want to um page
five has a
States what various drug categories have
either drawn up or gone down but I'd
urge you to turn to page 14 again buried
deep in the report representative
Edwards
um that um
so the slide on the slide on page 1415
are are um illustrative
um slide 14 talks about field
prescription counts shows a two-year
period from staple school year 21 and
22.
um opioid prescription counts down by
eight percent stimulant prescription
counts increased by 22 percent uh and
sedative prescription counts uh
decreased by five
um page 15 shows a five-year look back
which shows more dramatic increases and
decreases opioids down 23 percent over
this five-year period from 2018 to
present stimulants up 31 sedatives down
by eight
um not shown on the graph is a total
control substance prescriptions over the
five-year period have gone down four
percent on the state of uh in the state
of New Hampshire
um the slides that follow starting on
page 16 we have a we have an opioid
series of slides
um we see the decrease in opioid
prescriptions consistent not only across
prescription counts but also by day
supply and potency uh like I said there
are some location based slides as well
but it's not particularly meaningful to
say that zip 3 region
035036 saw the largest decrease
um
slide 24 I'd like to highlight want to
turn to that page
um
the state fiscal year 2022 8.4 percent
of all New Hampshire residents had at
least one filled opioid prescription uh
again this is down from uh from from the
previous year
um
the largest percentage uh being in the
60 and older age range which is
understandable due to uh
I would absolutely say that also I'd
also legislative efforts to you know to
to regulate
um the prescription opioid prescription
patterns are
key representative representative Weber
I'm I'm hearing representative Nagel's
voice in my ear but uh this also stems
from my own life experience
um
I was I was looking at the day's supply
of opioid prescriptions and that's
that's in the aggregate but I'm I'm
remembering a time when I was caring for
my late husband who had metastatic bone
disease and
um I'm wondering I'm just putting out
there because I don't see
I read this as thoroughly as I should
have up till now but I will uh I want to
put in the plug that for
uh particularly for long-term cancer
patients and other patients that need
opioid prescriptions for long-term pain
control and are being managed that way
and particularly for hospice care end of
life care that patients are getting
the medications that they need and the
uh number of days supply of pills that
they need to my late husband's
experience was that if he had one pill
there was a continuous application
say MSR MS Contin 30. he felt sick and
brain fogged all the time and he didn't
want to live like that if he was given a
larger supply of immediate release pills
at the 15 milligram level
he was able to
pick and choose when he wanted to be
clearer and when he wanted more pain
control and I hope that we are allowing
patients that kind of flexibility but
I'm worried that we aren't because his
experience was in the late 90s when they
were still being thrown around like
candy
and I don't know whether that's
something you can comment on or not
because I realized that most of your
stuff is in the aggregate yeah it would
be difficult to comment on that
um prescriber uh prescribing patterns of
opiates are
um are really are related but are
outside the the scope of what the pdmp
does which is you know which is
essentially a clinical tool a database
for uh for providers to look into to
make sure there's not over prescribing
but what you're talking about is exactly
that with in terms of mme where um
milligram uh morphine milligram
equivalent which does combine all uh
opiates into uh into one standard
um and it's a it's a national standard
that we all states use to aggregate
presentation of data
um
one follow-up sure
uh do you
um
slice the information that's currently
on on slide 18 which is the aggregate
number of days Supply that's out there
uh is there a way of determining the
number of days supply per individual
I mean it presumably would be just
dividing these numbers by the number of
prescriptions I'm I'm sure we could well
I I just I just thought it was
interesting that
if that's
being a liberal arts guy I can read it
read any sentence four ways and then
page 25
um with this big huge we write them as
another liberal arts graduate I write
them that way oh good thank you that's
why we communicated well
um page 25 it could mean the big jump of
21.3 percent under the zero to 19 year
olds is that these dentists with a
specialty are going opioid crazy or it
could mean that this is a new data
category that is coming in or it could
mean several other things which is a
because it's dangerous if it's one and
it's completely understandable if it's
the other
and can you find out and let us know
we can try to find out the cause I can
tell I can tell you like what the slide
says is that
um 50 of this increase is due to uh
prescriptions uh made by Oral Surgeons
um and so does that suggest that uh
there are more kids getting oral surgery
because of
um better access to Dental Care uh we
has the category of these dentists been
part of the data all along no no so it's
a new it's an addition is it yeah so it
doesn't mean the dentists are going up a
yard crazy it just means they're now
showing up in this particular place
correct okay yeah the chair yes since
the data is 21 to 22.
and we've had the crisis and we probably
deferred a lot of elective procedures
it could be that in 20 we didn't have
the kids come in to get their oral
surgery and in 22 we brought them all in
and
all those wisdom teeth
you had a backlog
that's entirely possible and and and
probably likely you do write good Pros
by the way any other questions
representative Edwards
um I'm curious I should maybe know
exactly what the this commission or this
board does uh what its Charter is but
are you
explicitly charged with trying to find
out the underlying reason behind Trends
or are you meant to be more of a
methodology and data collection
operation
undercar and guidance the latter this is
this is a this is more of a a data uh
repository
um and the issue that we have had with
pdmp data is that it is siled and the
the the difficulty
um that we have had historically of
sharing that data on any in any way that
is usable you know to those who might be
able to assess the data better
um has been a barrier
um similarly we're limited the amount of
data that we can take into the pdmp from
other areas you know like Medicaid and
so when I asked you earlier
why the use of stimulants have gone up
wondering if we now have a pending
problem that's outside the charter
that's outside the scope of your
organization to answer the why that
trend is happening we are limited in our
ability to make those assessments within
the EMP itself due to uh
statutory prohibitions on sharing and
utilizing data outside of our specific
program and Mr chair maybe someday you
could educate me on how we identify the
why when we get the data like this you
know who who do we go to to help us
understand I don't think that the people
who are making the presentations would
anticipate this as an interest of hours
income to do that
Mr Holt just testified it's outside the
scope of their responsibilities to
address the why I said that there are
there are legislative barriers to to
making those assessments and comparing
various data sets could you with your
super with your superiors craft some
language
that would help the legislature do just
we uh well he recovers representative
what we would we would uh we can we can
pull uh language that we've pulled for
many many years to be to allow the
department to access and utilize pdmp
data uh in more robust ways um we've
tried many many times and we've not been
successful in uh in expanding our data
representative
or am I not correct that we are now
running up against the issue of
the desire on one hand to collect
meaningful Health Care data across any
number of different platforms with the
other prevailing Trend that we have seen
particularly since the passage of the
Constitutional Amendment which is
protection of privacy and the trend
towards disallowing data to be
collected in a way that allows you to
slice and dice on a very local level
because or a very granular level because
that is much more likely to be
re-identified and to
then have people's most intimate stuff
shared with the general population and
we've been
dealing with that tension
for as long as I've been in the
legislature but currently we're on a the
the the the pendulum is swung towards
privacy rather than towards
public data
uh Public Health data collection
yes
only one way to understand that word
thank you Mr Page 25 a wise colleague
suggested to me that in order perhaps
better to explain
why the big black vertical column under
the zero to 19 you provide us
um previous year's iteration of this
chart like sfy 20 to 21 19 to 20. give
us a five-year retrospective before this
one so that we can lay them in a side by
side by side and maybe uh infer some
things wisely if you could do that
please
and representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair
um also remind the committee
that the prescription drug monitoring
program the database that's in that
program is an essence of medical
information
into your episode Weber's point of view
is the question at that point in time is
the
intense
concern about privacy when you get to
someone's medical record I think we all
should be very cognitive with the fact
how it gets utilized and where it's
released and so forth is extremely
important
number two to the why I think it goes
back to the licensing boards the issue
of why something is being prescribed is
a clinical decision
not a legislative one and I would
again conscious my peers here that we
somehow go back to the licensing boards
under the hospice of the prescription
monitoring program and saying was seeing
the spike but let the clinical people
understand what's causing the why and
not for us to try to get into it
legislatively I would be very willing to
do that thank you I agree with that if I
could follow up one thing please okay
and then I'm going to I would like with
your leave please to bring this
discussion to a close after your
follow-up because we still have the
State Office of rural Health's annual
report and Ms Hernandez have been
sitting there very patiently and I know
I'm able to stay a little bit longer but
not many not everybody may be so if we
could wrap it up I will
the other unintended consequence which I
think president Weber talked about
that's representative Nagel's brought to
our attention before
as much as we have a focus on the
mmes and so forth Etc the unintended
consequence is many times patients
because providers are very reluctant to
give the appropriate opiates to a
patient because they don't want it going
before the board or being highlighted by
the data there's that unintended
consequence where all of a sudden
providers get antsy about writing for
certain things inpatient care can go in
the opposite direction so I just want to
make people aware of that fact is that
we need to be monitoring things but be
cognitive of the fact that in the
monitoring process we're not
thank you
thank you and thank you Mr Holt thank
you very much
and you're not being given four minutes
you're given as long as you need and as
many of us can stay as long as we can
will stay and
um
the chair recognizes Danielle Hernandez
administrative division of Public Health
Services
for the annual report of rural health
and you brought a buddy with you and
yeah I did so I am also brought your
boss with you too yeah I brought
everybody with me
um I'm here to present this year's
annual report on the health status of
rural residents and health Workforce
data collection efforts by the Health
Professions data center this is a
statutory requirement of the State
Office of rural Health which sits under
rural health and Primary Care with
contribution by the health statistics
and data management office which my
colleague Dr Jessica sagona is here to
represent say the name slower please go
and what is your title
I'm a senior Public Health data analyst
senior wow
okay
okay so I'm gonna just highlight some
interesting parts of a very lengthy
report that you all have copies to and
can electronically access on the rural
health and Primary Care web pages
um so the first part of this report
covers the health status of rural
residents which our office determines by
revealing Health disparities that exist
between rural and non-rural residents in
the state and we break down rural
geography by overall aggregate region so
rural versus non-rural and by Regional
Public Health Network which is also
defined by morality
so we evaluate the help of the
population by analyzing Primary Care
Associated health indicators that reveal
access to and utilization and delivery
of primary care this includes
demographic risk factors like senior age
disability on insurance and so forth and
while we include a full list of the
evaluated indicators as an appendix and
the report that's appendix a only the
primary care Associated indicators found
to be statistically different by
geography are included in the data
summaries of the report one of the
exciting developments that we've
achieved over the last year is the
inclusion of a geographic filter for
rurality on the DHHS public facing data
portal so the data portal provides
aggregate Health Data statistics and
multiple multiple areas of Health like
chronic disease infectious disease
Community Health maternal and child
health substance use this will go so on
and so forth and the data portal now
provides users with the ability to drill
down to rurality for significant
differences summarized by graphics and
rates and many of the indicators on the
data portal were just put pulled
directly for this report those that
aren't on the data data portal as of now
and are in this report we plan on
integrating in in the next coming years
so the big picture here is
unsurprisingly there are significant
Health disparities between rural and
non-rural populations in the state when
considering population risk factors
access to Primary Care and health
outcomes rural populations are older
they're poorer they have higher rates of
visibility and on insurance travel times
to Health Care are longer Primary Care
Workforce Supply is lower
emergency department visits for
self-inflicted harm is higher smoking
during pregnancy is higher screening
rates for colonoscopy mammography and
two-year-old lead testing levels is
lower rural populations are less likely
to have had a checkup in the last year
and the proportion of late stage breast
cancer diagnosis and child lead levels
is higher in rural
across many of these categories of care
there are three regional public health
networks that really stick out against
the rest as having worse rates than
other individual Public Health regions
or aggregate region by morality that's
North Country Winnipesaukee and Carroll
County a few particularly troubling
rates stood out including 20 percent of
residents in Winnipesaukee indicated
they don't have a primary care provider
rates of no or late prenatal care is
almost twice as high in Winnipesaukee
than the aggregate World rate and the
age-adjusted death rate for North
Country and Winnipesaukee is about 15
percent higher than the aggregate rule
rate so these are obviously substantial
the exception to this pattern is for
alcohol and drug related inpatient
Admissions and pqis are prevention
quality indicators which are basically
preventable medical complications with
access to proper primary care so with
these indicators rural outperforms
non-rural populations overall
all right so and it's a very large
report and you have access to all the
detail there if you do
um take a look in Greater detail I'd be
happy to follow up with any questions
you have uh the second part of the
report focuses on our health Workforce
data collection efforts through provider
surveying um during license renewal and
leveraging Licensing data to more
comprehensively speak to supply in the
state when you mentioned the report and
it's extensive do you mean the executive
summary document so no that's involved
that's just the executive summary but
it's a 55 page report yeah and you
didn't make those oh good there is a
copy here it looks like that no it is
[Music]
thank you very much could we have copies
for us next month of course yes yes
um the data in the report reflects data
collected in 2020 as our turnaround time
for courses two years after data
collection and the workforce data
reports can be found again on our rural
health and Primary Care web pages for
medical provider types including
Physicians aprns and PAs and for
Behavioral Health Providers including
mental health practitioners alcohol and
drug counselors and psychologists these
reports contain survey participation
rates and dashboards on provider and
practice characteristics of the
workforces including practice status
demographics Education and Training
practice capacity access distribution
retention and Geographic disparity by uh
rurality
the office of professional licensure and
certification our oplc continues to work
very closely with our office to reduce
inefficiencies and administrative
burdens and increase survey compliance
which has obviously resulted in
increased response rates every cycle
year and this helps us accurately assess
the workforce Supply
now I'm gonna have you turn your
attention to uh one of the handouts in
your packet that's page 31 uh table 1.3
oh
there should be so the packet that has
the executive summary
yep
no
it's the stapled
yes yes
thank you
now what this table does is that
identifies changes in provider Supply
with providers lost so those providers
with an active license status that
didn't renew and providers gained those
that received an initial license in year
2020 and an analysis of the licensing
list found that none of the primary
medical or Behavioral Health workforces
experienced a true loss of providers
during this period in fact PA saw a
moderate gain about seven percent and
mental health practitioner saw a more
substantial gain about 12 percent it is
worth mentioning of course that because
this took place and the height of the
Copa 19 pandemic that it's unclear
whether there were providers just
maintaining an active license status and
not necessarily clinically practicing in
New Hampshire and those that were
clinically practicing was it at the top
of their license or were they simply
just aiding in the pandemic efforts
we're going to continue to track this
and it's going to be clarified in the
all right now the report also contains
data summaries for um the medical and
Behavioral Health workforces
um that could compare Supply and
capacity differences between provider
types and this includes significant
differences between the rural and
non-world practicing providers and
that's where I'm going to have you turn
your attention to the third page in the
before we do
um under uh mental health we have
psychiatrists psychiatric nurse
practitioners psychologists alcohol and
drug counselors do you also have licsw
counselors and the equivalent yes so the
mental health practitioners we do
collect data on and that includes licsws
lcmhc and so forth there was a data blip
and the reason why they're not contained
in here is because it came to light that
there's a Mal distribution of providers
by license license renewal year the
intention is for them to be be evenly
distributed across year but at some
point in the last 10 years or so the
boards of actually psychology and mental
health practitioners are mental health
practice decided to group all of those
that received an initial license before
the year 2000 all together in odd years
so now we have all of those that have
been practicing for a long time and of
older age all together in one group and
they're no longer you know an equal
distribution of cohorts
um and so at at that point we had to
wait another year in order to get those
summary the data summaries together page
three okay
um all right so page 36 here this is a
nice snapshot of the characteristics
shown to be significantly different
between rural and non-rural practicing
providers the same summary as I said
does exist for Behavioral Health
Workforce providers but I wanted to draw
your attention to this handout to really
just highlight the incredible value the
summary holds these measures which act
as indicators to Recruitment and
Retention are really critical for a
Workforce efforts they're used in
application for Grants to support and
strengthen the primary care Workforce so
you can see just in the first table
rural Physicians are more likely
um statistically more likely to have New
Hampshire ties to have worked or lived
in New Hampshire prior to receiving
their license to have attended a New
Hampshire Medical School which is guys
all to have trained in a residency
within New Hampshire and it's about
three times as likely as non-roll
practicing Physicians and less likely to
provide outpatient primary care services
and less likely to practice a mental
health specialty and that just speaks to
the shortage in rural so data like this
is directly used actually to justify the
need for Rural residencies like our
newly developed co-was and Cheshire
Family Medicine Residency programs and
also Workforce pipeline programs we used
it's like where's the trick
if you want to run for the house and
come into my committee all right
just wondered where it was up there
centered
pointing it early yeah I know where
you're pointing
okay good thank you thank you
you know we've known each other seven
um and then of course also Workforce
pipeline programs programs Fair headed
by UNH and Dartmouth
um most recently the the rural um
Healthcare Grant funds um that were able
to be secured by federal funding
um you know data like this helps in the
application so the Health Professions
data center really continues to show
immense value the data is used to inform
shortage designation which our office is
required to coordinate for New Hampshire
this brings providers and funding uh to
underserved areas of the state with a
lack of primary care providers and
because of shortage excuse me survey
implementation when a new shortage
designation was developed this year by
the health resources and services
Administration or hersa to identify
areas with a shortage of maternity
Health Care Providers our state was able
to accurately and quickly submit OB GYN
and certified nurse Midwife Supply data
data for designation and consideration
because it was already within our
capacity
um just as you know this is just an
example that data center provides
Workforce Supply capacity figures year
round to inform again grants Workforce
initiatives provider Association
activities
um internal reports through our
statutory requirement actually to inform
the planning and policy work of the
legislative Commission on the
interdisciplinary Primary Care Workforce
oh that's a mouthful
we work closely with members of the
commission to put the data into action
so we work with key stakeholders on the
commission including UNH Geisel the
medical association the nurse
practitioner Association the dental
Society citizens Health Initiative the
New Hampshire recruitment center and
many more
internal requests are frequent and this
year we've informed the work of maternal
and child health the oral health program
New Hampshire Ryan White program and and
more so the data center is really doing
exactly what the legislature intended
and that's providing critically needed
um uh data figures in order to tackle
the current and anticipated Primary Care
Workforce challenges in the state
no I'm just I'm I texted him
um you're still going you're still on no
I was just wondering I I I took the
opportunity while you were talking to
access your website so I could find the
report that we were talking about and
I'm really interested in the designation
of what's a an a rural area and what's a
non-rural area because I've I've
actually been to Washington
and to find it that it's an urban area
is a matter of some astonishment to me
um
how were the areas designated what was
the criteria for that so we use we
currently use population and population
density figures as there's a million uh
as you know right Federal definitions of
role within the office we use those
metrics to designate rural on the level
of just Regional Public Health Network
and all those towns that fall underneath
roll up however the question comes at a
good time because we are currently in
the midst of of changing the methodology
to actually drill down to defining rural
by town because of that exact reason
that there are these nuances within
Regional public health networks and for
Workforce considerations Lebanon and
Hanover right that sort of
um uh skews the true relationship and
this true shortages we see between rural
and non-rural because there's a wealth
of you know Healthcare that's provided
in those areas so once we were close to
finalizing we will certainly this year
and come out with a report that will be
publicly available and will be presented
to this commission but it will do a
better job growing up outside of Boston
as a kid I asked my parents what does
rural mean and they said New Hampshire
representative Weber thank you
um
if the designation is
keyed to provider networks I kind of
understand that but just looking at the
map itself I'm thinking about
um I I'm I'm applauding the idea of
drilling down a little more because uh
as several of us here have served on
several redistricting commissions know
as well uh there are towns that look on
a map like they're connected to
somewhere else and uh getting theya from
here is not easy and
um uh so
some of the towns here look like a
really false notion of how easy it is
and how proximal they are
to health care providers because of how
difficult it might be to get from from
one place to another in addition to the
fact of being
towns of very small populations so
absolutely and two-year refinement would
be really helpful and to your point
actually the new methodology we're
looking at wouldn't just use population
and population density metrics as we
currently are it's actually considering
mileage from the nearest population
Center and in New Hampshire that just
means Manchester and Nashua and we're
considering drive time to the nearest
Mr Speaker I have a question
um my wife is a Unicom graduate and you
may know that the University of New
England College of osteopathic medicine
was specifically
um the the savior of Saint Francis
College when they no longer needed to be
a francophone College in Biddeford and
it was the medical school was
established for Rural medicine in Maine
and some of the numbers of rural
providers in Maine are really heartening
um one of my uncles was one of them and
so my question is to what degree are you
going to be improving your link with
Unicom and might I suggest knowing a few
faculty and administrative people there
even to the point of perhaps a satellite
campus of Unicom
yes I'm not sure if um director Trisha
Tilley wants to speak more to this the
commission that I mentioned earlier in
the poor report actually does have two
Representatives that come
um you know with concerns of primary
care and how to sort of think through
the challenges of New Hampshire
um from une
um I'm not sure if there's any existing
relationships now
um between une and some of you know the
attempts and the rural areas to get
um you know recruitment over there and
pipeline work there unless this would
interrupt and some other people have to
leave I can speak with director Tilly
after the meeting
um and also
information right now but we have
several we have been connected with une
with some of the helpful Workforce
Development yeah we're good there's lots
of different pieces in the pie we could
come at another time and actually give
you a more comprehensive presentation on
that of all of the workforce initiatives
or at least you and I can sit down
because we have a big stake in une and
our we are a rotation clinical site
um also before you get back on track
um uh I text people in the audience
during the meeting to make me look
intelligent and uh one of one of my
usual suspects
um is to ask Danielle which legislators
to your knowledge participate with this
commission you mentioned
so we're actually currently in the
process of having a new uh
representative appointed to the
commission uh I know that that letters
um you know sort of uh being processed
now and I can't remember the name
we will get back to you we will get back
to you
um but previously it was representative
um Lori Harding
um yeah yes
um
right right I work extensively with the
speaker's office on recruiting and
nominating people to boards so if you
want me to grease the skids let me know
what you're doing I have a meeting up
there when we finish here but there's
been a backlog and they've asked me to
step in and help I remember now Jim
I'm going up there after this and I'll
make sure this gets expedited right okay
thank you
continue
unless there's a question representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman
I I see a lot of focus on the medical
side which is important obviously but
one of the questions I've heard before
this comment was working at the top of
the license yeah and given the fact that
it's time wise less time
involved and less constraint
with resources to help move along the
advanced nurse practitioners and PAs
what are we doing to try to increase
that Workforce because
if we can take some of the items that a
physician doesn't have to do
from a clinical point of view not the
legal point of view but down shifted to
that kind of personnel it would free up
a lot of the folks on the higher end to
do and take care of the patients at that
end of the spectrum versus trying to
constantly fill that void so is there
any work going on in New Hampshire to
try to find ways to take mid-level
practitioners and and enhance them so we
can take what time we do have with the
higher level practitioners to utilize
that time more efficiently effectively
it's a great question and I actually do
have a list maintained of all of the new
er since 2020 pipeline programs
um that have come into existence
um one of them is certainly a registered
nurse pipeline program I do work
actually closely with the Clinical
Director of the unh's NP fellowship
program
um although that's a little right
separate from being able to you know
have have duties be distinct and have
um focus on the the registered nurse
side of things it's not per se
registered nurse is looking at the nurse
practitioner which is a higher level
than an RN and trying to understand at
that point in time is growing that
mid-level Spectrum for
it's probably easier time wise resources
in order to get them educated at that
level than trying to go through the
medical schools and training they have
to go through become a physician just
trying to find what are we doing as a
state to try to enhance that mid-level
category of providers
so we can try to take what we do have on
the physician side which is the higher
end of the scale and utilize that time
as effectively as efficiently for
patient care as we can
with the chair's permission I can say
that one of the things that we're also
doing is that you come up to a live mic
so this gets recorded please as a
complimentary effort to that is the work
of um our state loan repayment program
which has really not only focused at the
top with the Physicians with all of the
mid-level providers so we're seeing you
know significant numbers of aprns coming
in Pas coming in that we're able to
support that way as well as the
mid-level providers in the behavioral
health space but to your other point of
how do we maximize them within a
practice I think that is a separate line
that we are working with some of the
pipeline you know to ensure that the
pipeline folks you know as they're
coming up through that they're well
prepared to work to the top of their
um capacity and then we certainly see
great you know examples of that like in
our fqhcs and other places that really
do know how to maximize the use of of
those providers there's more we could do
in that space But we're coming at it
with from like a bunch of different
angles slurp being one of the main ones
thank you
other questions so far
you're on a roll keep going oh I'm done
wow this then there's Jessica and she
can move close actually moving the mic
closer to you actually I don't have a
separate uh presentation she's here for
the technical questions around some of
the data sets representative Edwards
took this occasion to come up with a
question
so I'm I'm curious
um to what extent you crosswalk this
with other entities that are floating
around out there I I was specifically
there's a um a tele commission to study
telemedicine and you know what they
found was uh ironically telemedicine is
being used more in the non-rural areas
than in the rural areas and when we dug
into the why of that the why of that was
mostly a bandwidth issue to a lot of
places and so understanding the why
helped strengthen the idea that we
should support some band with
development issues out in the rural
areas of the state
so knowing why is important even if
we're not clinicians but but in any case
um the real question is do you there are
so many different entities looking at
the rural health problem I'm just
curious to to what extent you've
identified other entities with other
pieces that are relevant to the your
picture
many
um
working parts to this of course so where
we come in under rural health and
Primary Care you know is our focus on
access you know ensuring access to
Quality primary care for citizens of New
Hampshire to try to mitigate disparities
in the state of course you know along
with Health Care access or socioeconomic
there's behavioral there's Community
there's a lot of different legs of this
and I know that
um within you know I can't speak to the
whole of dphs and all of the efforts
going on under the division and even
really the community community efforts
all I can speak to is really our
specific work and sort of the entities
and the stakeholders we work with to try
to get this data out because now
remember that this report really serves
to inform policy by highlighting areas
of concern right so that we can address
them and it's getting it into the hands
of the stakeholders that make it action
people that can do something with it
follow up
okay so um in the ticker reporter in the
executive summary I was wanting to see
something that read like a recommended
Solutions or potential approaches you
know taking all of the ocean boiling it
down and just giving us okay so this is
what the smart people think we ought to
be doing from a policy perspective and I
did not see that no you didn't
um again because the aim of the Rapport
is sort of exploratory get the data out
there how can it be actionable but I
will say the other statutory requirement
that comes along with this report is to
again inform the work and policy
planning of that legislative commission
that I had mentioned earlier and in
their final report the data here is used
to inform that data report that has
recommendations on yes yes so they're
one of the entities of course again
before we use this data directly for
federal shortage designation as well for
State loan repayment program as well
which also is administered under rural
health and Primary Care to your
knowledge does that report of that
committee come here as well or will we
have to threaten one of our own members
to release it to us
I don't I guess not no I don't believe
so not as yet no but
um the final report
um is actually due in 20 next year and
2024.
um and that will have recommendations of
sort of all of this data that's been
collected over the last
um you know four years actually since
the the bill
um the bill passed that extended the
commission one is hoping June of 2024
because we start writing builds over the
summer and have to have them in by
November and if it is November of 2024
you've wasted a year
so I'm hoping that report's due date is
in the middle of 2024. it is November
1st but all right and let me tell you
that means no later than but it could
mean quite earlier then and it would be
in your advantage if it were earlier
then right
representative I also note that serving
on rules we just
um passed the resolution that we pass
every single year that says that reports
that come due in November uh that
recommend legislation uh we give a
blanket pass
from the reporting from from the filing
deadlines so
the filing deadlines for next year are
going to be very limited September
window but we always every year need to
recognize the fact that there are many
committees and commissions that report
sometime right around the beginning of
November and often recommend legislation
and so every year if it is recommended
by the majority of a sitting committee
that legislation is
automatically given a blanket
pass on the deadline so that it can be
drafted and and started without waiting
a whole nother 12 months
thank you for that
as a wise man once said that's on the
house side I don't know how they do it
any other questions pretty much we do
the same thing it's just not as formal
passing a minute yeah we have 400 people
we have to do it this way any other
questions anything else you want to give
does uh director Tilly wish to add
anything
I simply want you make Danielle
um for coming today because we have had
a change in the Primary Health Care
section we had an individual Lisa
trustbuck who had been in that role for
18 years she has just transitioned into
working in the um philanthropic
Community Sean Jackson just moved from
pdmp to this role so there's been a
tremendous amount of transition and
Danielle's done a great job preparing
this report and is this the Mr Jackson
and the two other people who are going
to give me business cards when we're
done
I would say if I had purchased them for
him he would give them to you as Click
and Clack said you can always write it
on the back of a 20.
do you have a business card I do I do
you have made a name
so anyway I think we have come to a
wonderful and happy conclusion and keep
those cards and letters coming thank you
and welcome and we are done
email contact information yes yes Mr
Jackson at least your email contact up
here please I'll give you a card
nevertheless